vaccines never have they been talked
about more but how can they help keep us
safe in the coming months before winter
begins to bite
these medics are urging people to come
forward for a vaccination we haven't
spoken about as much this year
the flu
in a campaign that launches today
people are being encouraged to book
their injection as soon as possible to
protect themselves and their loved ones
modeling suggests hospital admissions
and deaths caused by seasonal flu could
be two times that of a normal year
the combination of rising covert cases
low immunity against the flu after a
year of social distancing and indoor
socializing for the festive period could
prove catastrophic for the nhs
that is why gps like dr sarah jarvis are
encouraging not just the
immuno-compromised but people young and
old to get a shot
people are congregating they're not
socially distancing in the way they were
last year which meant that there was
virtually no flu to add to winter
pressure the nhs always comes under huge
pressure in winter this year we may well
have high cases of flu we're adding
covid into the mix and we've got a huge
backlog of people far more people than
usual needing care because they didn't
have it during the first and second
waves when hospitals were close to
anybody who didn't have covert
but who exactly can act on this call to
action
the flu vaccine is being offered to
those over 50
pregnant those with health conditions
residential care front line health
social care workers carers and those who
live with someone who is vulnerable
one concern to address in the coming
months is the hesitancy which we've seen
curb kovitjab take up among minorities
so you need
the government and the
public health messaging
to go into those communities more and
talk to people in their community
because we are sort of a multi-racial
multi-ethnic multidimensional society
you have to
and you have to address all those
different groups in different ways
the store supply and rollout of
kovitjabs has been vital this year
saving thousands of lives
now as the temperature plummets people
are being asked to take another
injection in the hope of saving
thousands more shinki marike sky news